Hey Sam, so yeah, we spoke through I
thought you were my sister, I'm sorry.
Go ahead. No, no worries. Uh through the
email communication and uh
I would I guess I'm just, you know, like
terrified or scared of what what my
family is going to think, you know, and
cuz you know the cult you know the
culture. Yeah, but what is the religious
background of your family?
Muslim.
Okay, so
>> Very staunch, very staunch Muslim. Oh,
really? Well, are you living in a Muslim
country?
No, I actually live in Denver, Colorado.
Oh, yeah, yeah, you don't need to go
away too much details, but all right.
Okay, so
you
have already exited Islam because I from
my the email I thought you were saying
you're looking into Islam and
Christianity. Mm. No, no, no, no. I uh I
I was looking actually it's it's kind of
a a long story. For some for some
context um Yeah, give us tell us so we
can know what your background is so I
know how to help you.
You know, uh 2025 was like a like really
bad year for me, you know, I I lost my
job, uh my fiance, uh some other
personal issues, and um
just going through a hard time, you
know, and um
um my father, it's actually ironic
because my father is very staunch
Muslim, you know, and it's ironic that I
found Jesus through him telling me,
"Hey, you you know, just pray more. Just
mix a lot more, you know, just uh look
into the Quran more, look into the
prophet's life because he's a perfect
man, you know, so you you look into
these things more and you will you will
find a way."
And uh it's ironic because
the more I prayed, the the more the more
abandoned I felt. I felt nothing, you
know, and um
the more I looked into the Quran, I just
it didn't make sense to me, and and
there's a lot of contradictions and
things
that I that and it just doesn't make
sense to me that it would lie, you know,
about the crucifixion of Jesus and
>> yourself
that the crucifixion is a fact, huh?
Well,
according to a lot of historic evidence
and peer review, you would have to, you
know, by common sense, by default, you'd
have to believe it.
You know, and um
Yeah, and then I started looking into
the the life of Muhammad and it's very
easy. You can just go on YouTube and,
you know, life of Muhammad and you will
see some videos where only talks about,
you know, the good things he did and and
all that.
But then when you really dig deep into
it, you you you find out that this guy
did some like really narcissistic
monstrous things, you know,
with, you know, the child marriage and
and murdering of of hundreds of
thousands of men,
beheading men and taking wives and yeah,
and and children into slavery and all in
the name of of Allah, right? It's that's
the the the claim.
That he he was a prophet and and these
revelations came to him. So it just
didn't make sense to me that
a just God would give him revela- such
violent revelations, you know, or such
perverted such perverted revelations.
Uh is as so, you know, so to and then if
you take away the title of prophethood,
you realize, okay, this man was just a
monster.
You know, so it it made me very sick and
I I just I couldn't believe, you know,
what I was what what I was learning.
And then in in Isa, Jesus is in the
Quran and I thought to myself, you know,
I was I thought to myself, well, you
know, why do we why do we follow the
teachings of Muhammad when when Jesus
was a perfect man.
Precisely. So, for me, like even
throwing out all the arguments from the
Bible or or the Quran, you can make any
argument. If you just reduce it to the
fact of how did this one guy live his
life and how did this other guy live his
life, it's kind of clear who
who you should follow who you should
follow, you know? You don't have to be a
scholar,
you know, in my opinion. So,
Well, that's true.
>> where I'm at. That's where I'm at. So, I
choose to follow
>> your hesita- So, what's hesita- what's
causing you to hesitate to become
Christian or what's going on?
I'm not hesitating. I I I think I
consider myself Christian. I've been
going to Sunday Sunday prayer for quite
some time now with with some people.
But, my biggest thing I think is what
my parents don't know.
Well, how old are you?
I'm 40 years old.
You're not a young kid, brother.
I understand, but you but you know the
community. You know the Muslim
community. Jesus knew the computer
community better than you and me cuz the
Jewish community is similar to Middle
Eastern and non-Middle Eastern Islamic
community. We're all from that part of
the world where community's big. So,
Jesus already said,
"You're going to have to count the
cost."
So, if you're more scared of rejection
or backlash then he goes, "You're not
worthy of me."
Here he says it. So, Jesus said it. It's
not like you're in Saudi Arabia where
you have to be in hiding.
You're in America. You're 40. You're
grown man. The first persecution gets
bad, you leave.
It's if you were in a Middle Eastern
country, I'd give you different advice
cuz here
our Lord himself says it. He knows
better than you cuz he was raised in
that environment when he became man. The
ancient Middle Eastern culture is the
Islamic culture cuz Islam was reared in
Middle Eastern culture.
Same culture. Honor and shame. You can't
lose face. You can't shame your people,
your family.
It's It's uh worse than death. All
right. Well, here's what our Lord said.
Matthew 10:34-39.
Here's what he says.
"Do not think that I came to bring peace
on the earth. I did not come to bring
peace, but a sword.
For I came to set a man against his
father and a daughter against her
mother,
and a daughter-in-law against her
mother-in-law, and a man's enemies will
be the members of his household." Now,
understand what he means. He's not
saying he comes to make you hate people.
He's saying, "Because of your faith in
me,
those family members of yours who hate
me will hate you.
So, whether you like it or not, when I
come into the world,
my coming and your acceptance of me will
bring a division."
And you confirming the words of our
Lord, he spoke this 2,000 years ago. Cuz
you just testified Jesus
>> Yes. Yes. 2,000 years ago
knew
what's going to happen, proving he's not
fake, he's God, cuz he's telling you,
"You follow me, your family will be
divided."
>> to cause It's going to cause division,
yes. Yeah, I understand.
>> I watch what he goes on to say. "He who
loves father or mother more than me is
not worthy of me.
He just said it black and white in your
face.
You kept saying my father, my mother.
Yeah, I understand that, but for me
it's, you know, life I consider life
transcendental, like uh
Like you can say my mom My father is
just an earthly matter, you know, God.
>> why you worried about becoming
Christian?
>> God deserves more love than than
anybody, of course.
>> All right. Well, you just said testify.
Jesus said, "All right. What's stopping
you?
He who loves son or daughter more than
me
>> Yeah.
It's just hard, you know. I mean,
you understand the Muslim community that
I might I could lose what I could lose
my family, you know. And then Jesus
said,
"So what? You just said it's transient.
You're going to lose them anyway at
death.
And then if you keep on to them, you're
going to still lose them. They're going
to die. But then you lose me forever
because he told you it is hard. He who
does not take his cross and follow after
me is not worthy of me. Is cross
something painful or pleasant?
What is a cross representing? Something
painful or pleasant?
To me, something pleasant.
You know. Really? So when they were
nailing people to cross, they're like,
"Wow, I feel so great. I feel like I'm
in a swimming pool."
>> No, of course. Of course, painful. But
the today's representation
>> about? The pain losing your family.
That's what you want to get out of. He
just told you. Yes. Yes.
That's the metaphor he's giving you. I
see. I see. I see.
Cross is painful.
He says, "So I'm letting you know, I'm
not lying to you cuz these cannot lie.
Following me is not going to be easy.
You're going to suffer. But then you're
going to have to think about it. Is it
worth it?"
Well, your actions speak louder than
your words. You can say yes, but then
when you cower and walk away, you're a
liar.
You don't think I'm worth it. You don't
believe.
I definitely do not believe the Quran.
Yeah, but he's telling you you
definitely do not believe in me when you
don't go
and submit to me in baptism. He who has
found his life will lose it.
And he who has lost his life for my sake
will find it.
See, I already answered you 2,000 years
ago.
I don't need to answer you. He answered
you.
Yeah, I I I understand. I understand.
It's just, you know, a very very hard
decision.
I guess the I guess the advice I'm
looking I guess the advice I'm looking
for is, you know, how
how do I even tell how do I tell them?
How should I tell them?
>> I'm confused that you're 40 years old.
You're not dependent on them.
Do you Do they You have to tell them too
about, let's say, what job you work?
No. No.
Do you have to tell them about
Mhm.
what gym you go to? Cuz I don't know
your lifestyle.
Sure. Sure. Do you have to tell them
what gym you go to?
It Like, Mom, can I go out to the gym at
this time? What time you want me to be
back? Is that the kind of control they
have? You got to tell them when you
leave, when you come back, and what
time, and who you can be with, who you
can't be with?
I I Yeah. No, I understand what you're
saying, Sam. You know, it's just my
>> you know the answer.
>> My father comes from like very staunch
line of of Muslims. He's going He's
going to be disappointed, you know?
You don't You don't get more staunch
than the Jews in the 1st century that
also killed other Jews who became
Christians.
So, let's make your dad happy and make
Jesus disappointed. Is your dad going to
die?
Eventually, yes. You're going to lose
him eventually?
Yes.
So, even if you appease him now, you're
still going to lose him.
And you're so worried. Look Now, let me
tell you Look how you really are. Do you
believe Jesus is the only hope of
salvation?
Yes. Yes. And yet you're going to leave
your father as a Muslim so he can go to
hell cuz you're worried about him.
>> No, and that was another question, you
know, I had for you because I don't want
my father to go to hell. And Well,
you're both going to go to hell the way
you're going cuz you're not willing to
take a stand.
Yeah. Yeah.
I want I want to bring him to Jesus. I
just don't don't know how to how to
approach that subject, you know? Because
you're too afraid of his reaction.
I think he deserves it. He's my father
is like very good man, you know, very
very
>> so it's good enough that you're going to
let him go to hell? You just said Jesus
is the only savior, so I'm confused. I
really don't understand you. You just
told me there's no salvation apart from
Christ and my father is a good man, so
let me not offend him knowing that if he
stays Muslim he goes to hell.
That's how good of a man he is that
you're going to let him go to hell?
No, no, no. I I I understand what you're
saying, son. I don't know. You keep
saying you understand what I'm saying,
but what are you going to do about it?
That's what I'm trying to get at.
I'm going to tell them, of course. It's
just
So then you made your decision and
you're going to have to carry the cross
and suffer the consequences.
That's it. Oh, you became Christian, you
dishonored us. Yeah, but Dad, the
evidence points to Christianity.
What evidence? That's where they're
going to challenge you and bring up the
>> It's going to become Yes, it's going to
become a war, you know, because of his
faith because of how how deep in the
faith that they are on that side of the
family.
>> Brother, it's of course it's going to be
a war.
And I'm I don't know and I also I'm new
I'm new I'm a new Christian, so I I
don't Well, I'm not going to know how to
defend myself other than I know that I
feel that it's the truth.
>> then go and get baptized, go to the
church and when they found out then you
take it from there.
Take it from there.
You got to worry now first about you
overcoming your fear of man
and fearing Jesus more than man
and then commit yourself to Christ and
then pray and grow in your faith and
pray for the opportunity to witness to
your parents.
But in the meantime, the excuse making,
right? Excuse making will not only will
anger God towards you, but will prolong
your
opportunity [clears throat] to witness
to your parents cuz the longer you
delay, the greater the chance you have
you're going to lose your father, mother
to death, and according to you, they're
not saved. So, where do they go?
To hell.
And so, you're going to delay
your witness to them to save them
thinking you have tomorrow, but what if
you die today and they die today?
Yeah. Yeah.